[Música]
y yo hoy con mi cuerpo me llevo muy bien
antes no me pasaba eso por el hecho de
que tampoco me conocía
a mí no me hizo conocerme mucho
me mostró información sobre lo que me
había pasado las cirugías por las cuales
tuve que pasar
me ayudó también a
a poder quererlo a poder tocarlo
explorarlo y hoy en día tengo una muy
buena relación no me importa tanto
mostrarlo no lo llevo con orgullo porque
también me di cuenta que es una forma de
lucha mostrarlo es una forma de
expresarme también y si lo uso como como
canal
y la voz también me parece que la hoja
fue lo primero que utilizamos
utilicé son en realidad que utilice yo
porque en realidad todos tenemos
expresiones diferentes
y muchas
como se dice muchas acciones
que lo hacemos mediante el cuerpo de
muestran
nuestros pasados entonces
creo que es súper que es súper
importante la voz y el cuerpo como
método de expresión y bueno yo hoy por
suerte tengo una muy buena relación pero
esto no pasa siempre
[Risas]
claro sí sí el diario en donde escribí
mi historia donde escribí cómo me sentía
donde escribía
bueno todo lo que pasaba también es un
método de expresión es mi método de voz
es lo que contaba la cocodrila
es súper importante no solamente el
escrito lo que estaba bueno era que el
diario lo hacía también audio con el
teléfono con el micrófono que tiene que
quiera otra alternativa cuando no tenía
ganas escribir
a mí me pasó como decía rocío también
fue la voz lo primero que surgió
es como tenías todo atragantado y de
repente sale todo
igual pero después es como que me di
cuenta que el cuerpo era algo muy
importante que algo que lo llamamos
siempre pero nunca le damos la
importancia que tiene es como que no lo
escuchamos y siempre habla
constantemente y entonces como wow
ponerse a escucharlo y decir todo lo que
me está diciendo cómo se siente porque
actúa de esa manera porque se enferma de
esa manera y es como a lo tengo escuchar
y expresar a través de él entonces me di
cuenta que es un canal es un canal que
ahora me parece muy importante estudio
teatro y es mi instrumento de trabajo
entonces constantemente es escucharlo
saber que necesita y expresar a través
de él y tanto de la voz también y ya
había como antes que empecemos la pelea
había como un corte entre esta capacidad
de pensar y entender y esta capacidad de
incapacidad de moverse
si es como que era como todo desde aquí
arriba muy lógico y pasó como
al cuerpo entero de expendio
porque no quiero ser cómplice con el
secreto de familia con todos los
cómplices adultos que hacen llegar a los
llevar a los niños ese tipo de situación
porque lo real
por más cruel que se ha dicho con poesía
es lo real y es mi
mi tarea número uno como
realizadora como directora como poeta
como mujer como vecina como tía como
bastante de ponerme del lado del que
sufre de que sufrió y no del lado del
que atacó abusa entonces sin lanzar una
guerra era muy importante también
puedo decir que mi cuerpo y mi relación
con el cuerpo cambio con las chicas
porque lo que conociendo lo que ellas
viven y como lo hemos tratado te da
menos vergüenza y sentir el cuerpo te
sentir ridícula ay no me puse yo porque
tengo celulitis y entonces te das cuenta
hasta qué nivel estamos infectados por
una serie de valores que ni siquiera lo
defendemos pero hasta criamos así
entonces este de la forma como yo hago
las películas así es que nos ponemos
todos en el mismo nivel y trabajamos
todos por una causa entonces todos
aprendemos algo todos recibimos algo
todos damos algo y estamos convencidos
que no es la misma persona quienes damos
las personas que nos van a volver a dar
entonces si se arma como un círculo
filosóficamente mucho más sólido para
seguir y es socialmente súper directo
porque cada vez que estamos en las
he dado mucha vuelta con esta película
desde hace 8 meses las chicas también y
es impresionante lo que comprobamos que
no solamente nosotras sino que el equipo
y el público están transformando
su vida gracias a una historia que está
contada con mucho
muchas metáforas para poder entrar de
diferentes perspectivas sin ser
sensacionalista
con el respeto y con la verdad entonces
la piel y la piel
que me calle no me quede callada basta